the u.s postal service can trace its
roots back to our country's founding but
it faces growing questions about its
relevance today
even as it does some big things the
white house recently called on the post
office to deliver at-home cova tests to
all americans who want them and of
course we recently leaned on them for
mail-in voting historically it's
delivered just about anything anywhere
you can still send live geese bees or
scorpions eggs cremated remains even
though you cannot as you once could ship
your kids off to relatives in a
different town
but for all the wonder it's inspired the
postal service is struggling with
increased competition and gigantic
losses leading to budget cuts and slower
service this has led some to ponder if
the post office even has a place anymore
in our modern digital world we found one
community where folks would tell you it
most certainly should
fewer than 500 people live in the tiny
hamlet of alpaz new york and for years
your best chance of running into any one
of them was the post office that was
where you could find other neighbors
and you could find dog biscuits and
books and donuts and coffee and gossip
when we visited last fall we learned
that even when home delivery was an
option most still preferred a p.o box
most of us chose to have a box because
we loved to make the daily visit to the
post office but today at the spot where
the post office once stood a gazebo has
taken its place
it's been 10 years since the postal
service abandoned its location in zip
code one two zero zero eight you're
closing my office and terminating my
position the closure inspired a 2019
indie film called colwell
kathy boyle was postmaster here in real
life until the office shut down what did
that do to the community everybody was
devastated i had warned people you know
you better get ready put your mailboxes
up to people who had p.o boxes and get
them up just in case it was incredibly
sad day when we had to put a mailbox
outside the house at the end of the
driveway
that sense of sadness is a familiar one
in small town america since the growth
of rural home delivery in the early
1900s more than 50 thousand post offices
have closed the communities that do
experience postal closures they would
tell you they're not quite the same evan
kalish would know on his blog postlandia
he's documented visits to post offices
in all 50 states north rim arizona
passionately if not obsessively
collecting dozens of postmarks along the
way obsessive would be if i did all the
international post offices too okay so
then your preferred term for this hobby
of yours is what enthusiastic you're an
enthusiast i'm very enthusiastic albeit
what drives his enthusiasm he says in
part is the usps's obligation to provide
service to everyone it is rather
egalitarian every place every person is
treated equally no matter if you're in
the desert of nevada or in the heart of
new york
you can get the same service for the
same price they will deliver a letter to
every nook and cranny of this country
they're the only
agency entity that's capable of doing so
ups and fedex will
deliver many of their packages to the
postal service for what's known as the
last mile delivery so imagine that even
the companies cutting into the post
office's business rely on what surveys
have deemed to be america's most trusted
government agency
and america's most trusted brand overall
the postal service plays an integral
part in the lives of americans of every
age and station with deliveries by horse
boat train bike car and plane the postal
service helped build this nation and
created a bond with its citizens
dating all the way back to its creation
in a 1792 law signed by president george
washington he wanted to make sure people
shared the same information that it was
accurate and that there was there was a
common american culture and that's
really what the postal service was all
about but devin leonard author of
neither snow nor rain a history of the
united states postal service says the
agency's best days are behind it nobody
really wants to have an adult
conversation about what's happening with
the postal service and and that is that
people don't really need it like you
know like like they used to over the
years new innovations have chipped away
at the postal services business the
telegraph and later the telephone
reduced the need for letters private
shipping companies offered other options
for sending goods and the internet has
made it easier to do just about
everything people do have this great
affection and nostalgia for the postal
service but if they're not using it
you know kind of what good is that is
the postal service just not a part of
the future of america the way it was a
part of the past what it's definitely
not the agency is also billions of
dollars in the red in part because of a
2006 law requiring it to set aside
funding for health benefits for workers
retiring
decades from now so if the decline of
the postal service continues is that a
tragedy or just a reality or both
i think it's a tragedy you know in that
it's this great institution with you
know with this great history the
question is do we need it now
you know in the age of the internet and
certainly not to the extent that we used
to
the mail in outlaws now comes from the
nearby town of rexford just a
three-minute drive from where the old
post office once stood
but for the people here that short trip
has taken them far away
from each other what do you say to
somebody watching this who doesn't
really get it they say look there's
another post office a mile a mile and a
half down the road
what's the big deal
you're not going to understand what's
the big deal
unless you've lived it this is a
connection to the past
and the post office was
the symbol of community i think that's
more than anything
current postmaster general louis de joy
announced a long-term plan last year
that according to the postal service is
helping stabilize the workforce improve
operations and increase investments in
facilities and equipment but that plan
also includes cutting post office hours
and lengthening delivery time so
performance will go down it seems yeah i
mean you know we can all say it took a
long time to get the letter but it does
come and the people that work there
really do care about getting you your
mail yeah they really do everyone that
you've met that works at the post office
if you've gotten to know your local
letter carrier they care deeply i would
hate to see that it disappear it's it's
hard to say but technology and the
evolution of
yeah it creates the declination of what
we know as the poster speaking of that
we're going to get you on email soon gil
don't worry one letter we'll be right
back i like a handwritten note